Ashley Madison is a website that
advertises life is short have an affair
recently it was hacked exposing 37
million adulterous email addresses to
the world the saddest username who's
your daddy 69 the saddest password love
hurts only three ZIP codes in the entire
United States had no Ashley Madison
accounts so did everyone get the affair
of their dreams
well the hack revealed that an
overwhelming 86% of users were male 31
million men - 5.5 million women but
Gizmodo discovered that 70,000 of those
women were actually fake accounts
created and operated by Ashley Madison
they sent 20 million messages to men and
engaged 11 million mail users in chats
because if men thought they were getting
somewhere with a woman they'd keep
paying to use the site where is a
cheating women if they're not on Ashley
Madison
maybe tinder 30% of users are married
and nearly 40% of them are female but
back to the hack thoughtfully looking
after user privacy Ashley Madison
offered a full account deletion service
for only $19 in 2014 alone Ashley
Madison netted 1.7 million in revenue
from this full delete promise but a
total of 185 thousand nine hundred and
forty six email addresses found in the
hack were listed as paid delete so uh
they were still on Ashley Madison
servers and didn't really get deleted
people are pissed and feeling exposed
the whole mess has revealed an
interesting side of modern relationships
namely that a lot of married people
aren't as satisfied as they seem yet
among Millennials 88 percent of women
and 77 percent of men think that
flirting online is cheating and
unsurprisingly 1/3 of divorces in recent
years name online cheating as a culprit
so it's not like people are okay with it
even if they are doing it all the time
so what do you think is it cheating to
sign up for Ashley Madison even if you
never actually meet up with someone and
if you were one of the unlucky users
exposed in the hack well maybe next time
don't use your actual email address